Hi, I'm Mike.
Hi, I'm Min.
Nice to meet you.
So you're an international student here at Benedictine.
Yeah, I want to open a checking account.
Okay, great.
Do you have a visa?
Yeah.
Is your passport with you? And your student ID; make sure you got them today.
That's all we need.
It's just the visa and the student ID, great.
Okay, perfect.
Alright, all I need you to do is just fill in the first couple box:..
...name, address and day of birth.
And I'll give you an idea a little bit about how the account works.
Okay.
The main benefit and the main features that we have for the Citibank student account...
...is the fact that the account has no fees, absolutely no minimum balance,...
...and there's no social security number required.